GOVERNMENT HEARING HER FOR ANY
MEMBERS MISSING PLEASE ARRIVE
BUT WE DO HAVE A QUORUM OF
SECRETARY TECHNICAL ROLE PLEASE
AGUIAR-CURRY PRESENT HERE
LACKEY BLOOM. BLOOM HERE
BOERNER HORVATH RAMOS RAMOS
HERE GONZALEZ EXCUSE ME. RIVAS.
VOEPEL VOEPEL HERE. AND
THREE OF US. THREE OF US HERE.
OKAY THIS IS THE LAST. WE HAVE
ONE ITEM TO HEAR AYE
CONCURRENCE AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
TWO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS WELCOME THANK YOU
MEDICARE I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK
YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY TWO
. THE PROJECT
EMPLOYEES ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY SLANT WELL TECHNOLOGY
AS RECOMMENDED IN THE
CALIFORNIA OCEAN PLANNED AND
ENJOYS BROAD SUPPORT FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS LABOR
GROUPS AND THE LOCAL COMMUNITY.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY TWO MY BILL
WILL ENABLE US TO BRING THIS
PROJECT TO FRUITION
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY REQUIRES THAT AT
THE PROJECT USES SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE. FOR PROJECT
COMPLETION IT'S A WIN WIN AND
DIET RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY AND PLEASED TO
INTRODUCE JACKSON WALKER HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ABOUT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JACK
WELCOME BEHALF OF THE SELF
BECAUSE WATER DISTRICT THE
AUTHOR HAS REALLY LAID OUT THE
BILL AND WE WANT TO THANK HER
FOR PICKING THIS UP AT A
CRITICAL TIME IN THE SESSION
WHEN WE REALIZED. THAT THE
STATUTE WAS EXPIRING SO IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS WE NEEDED
THIS MEASURE SO WITH THANK YOU
FOR CARING AND CERTAINLY
ENCOURAGE YOUR VOTE TO
RECOMMEND CONCURRENT AND I'VE
ALSO BEEN DEPUTIZED. BY THE
CESSATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES THE METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND THE MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT OF ORANGE COUNTY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
JAMIE MINOR BEHALF OF SANTA
MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROJECT THANKS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
COMMITTEE GERMAN SMITH YOUR
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO SUPPORT. SURE MEMBERS
DON'T GIVENS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
GREAT. THANK YOU ANY OF THOSE
IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE. NOT
A ONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO I NEED
A MOTION TO A RUSSIAN YET SO
WE- CAN. WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
IT JUST LIKE TO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR YOUR HELP IN NOT IN WORKING
WITH US TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
WE'RE HONORED TO HELP YOU OUT
IT JUST WAS A TIMING THING AND
LIKE USUAL IN THIS BUILDING SO
WITH THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY. SIR TAKE TAKE
THE ROLE. THE MOTION IS TO
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY HI
LACKEY BLOOM. BLOOM I
BOERNER HORVATH RAMOS. THE
SILOS RIVAS THIS RIVERSIDE
ROBERT RIVAS. VOEPEL AYE. BILLS
OF FIVE ZERO BEFORE WE GO ANY
FURTHER I WANT TO THANK AT MY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
THEIR WORK SO HARD THIS YEAR
I'M GONNA MISS NOT SEEING THEM
EVERY DAY I MUST ADMIT THANK
YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK I WANT TO
ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE MY FELLOW WILL
BE LEAVING ME SOON IT'S CELL
AND I'M HOPING SHE GOES TO
WATER WORLD ANYBODY BUT ANYWAY
I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE AND THE SPEAKER STAFF
KATIE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THIS YEAR.
IT'S BEEN A WONDERFUL YEAR
WE'VE GOT A LOT MORE WORK TO DO
NEXT YEAR AND WITH THAT ADJOURN
THE MEETING OKAY. I GOTTA WAIT.
OUT ON SITE. THANK YOU I DON'T
HAVE ALL IT WAS AN OFFICIAL IT
WAS. A TOP DENTURE. THANK YOU.
WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THE NEXT FIVE MINUTES. YEAH.
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I. RIGHT YEAH. YEAH THE LAST
MEETING THAT ACTUALLY YEAH
FRASER'S USE MISTER LACKEY. WHY
YOU WENT DOWN AT ALL PERFECT
OKAY SO THAT YOU'VE GOT FOUR
MINUTES THIRTY SECONDS. THERE'S
NO ONE. WELL LET'S MAKE SURE
HE'S ACTUALLY. YEAH BY THIS IS
AN AREA. NOTHING
. THE WAY FOR.
HOME OKAY. THIS IS LANCE. YEAH.
THIS IS A LETTER OF. YEAH. THE
PHONE. I YEAH. LACKEY LACKEY
LACKEY AYE
. YEAH. NOTICES ON
THE- MAIN THE MAIN COMMON. YEAH
YEAH. RIGHT YEAH MY NAME. YEAH
YEAH. YEAH RIGHT RIGHT YEAH.
YEAH YEAH YEAH. NOTHING RIGHT
YEAH. YEAH I GOT A- IT WAS THE
RIGHT
. I HAVE BEEN LIKE CAN I
AM GETTING A BETTER OKAY. IT
WAS JUST LIKE ONE OF THE NUMBER
AND LIKE. YOU SAID. OKAY MAYBE
NOT. EVERYTHING. I. YEAH YEAH.
YEAH. YEAH I THANK. YEAH. WE
DIDN'T KNOW IF IT EVER. YEAH.
YEAH YEAH YEAH. YEAH. YEAH.
OKAY THE. I DON'T KNOW YEAH.
YEAH. YEAH NO I MEAN NO LONGER.
NUMBER YEAH YEAH. YEAH. YEAH
.
ONE YEAH YEAH OKAY
. HOW. YEAH
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVERSIDE I
GOT. LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
IS ADJOURNED